I visited the Warner Brothers animation
studio here on The WB lot I had a little
visit with them and I sat down with
legendary animator Bruce Timm and
together we cooked up a Conan superhero
where he was illustrating and I was just
throwing out a bunch of ideas and
together we cooked something up check it
out
I want my belt with things thing that
holds my blackberry on a style I see but
maybe with flames coming off oh and a
star David behind it mix maybe there's
some steam coming off the mint so a
highlight glove and the other one you
know what I would like to be the first
guy that's wearing shoes like loafers
how about sauce like an old man's socks
with garters fishnets and garters and
socks yes this is remarkable look at
that
yeah so I thought that was it we were
just screwing around we showed that on
our program well today Warner Brothers
animation sent us this clip from Young
Justice on the Cartoon Network and I
think it speaks for itself
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
we are not happy Justice League systems
disobeyed direct orders and endangered
lives you will not be doing this again I
am sorry but he will Aqualad
stand down apologies my king but no we
did good work here tonight the work you
trained us to do it's simple
get on board or get out of the way
[Music]
Yeah right I think though I have to tell
you this just showed up today I am very
excited about this there's a lot of
money this thing turned into a movie The
Flaming see this could be really big
oh yeah and they've nailed my oh yeah
they've nailed my voice pretty much I
just kind of had like two complaints one
I think I should be the only superhero
with a beard
they put look at this they put who is
that Aquaman right next to me we look
like two guys that are it has some kind
of relationship look at that and look
the flash is jealous the flash I saw him
first
the other thing is I don't know I don't
understand the plot of this I don't know
what they're talking about and who is
this freaking magician look is that why
is the magician that you would hire for
a kids party is my one of my helpers I
don't understand so I think we have some
things to iron out but I'm gonna see to
it and I think we're gonna try and get
more clips okay I think the flaming see
could be the biggest thing
the steam off that oven mitt
he has the power to touch people and
make them slightly warm yeah
[Music]